alain de la morandais
halladay fif et moi le mariage via un
prince un curé là ce soir un est dans la
merde alors aucun vrai prince il parle
comme ça on dirait relais dire
nous on va relever le niveau rassurez
vous alain maillard de la morandais on
va vous appeler mon père
si vous êtes mon fils oui oui mais je
vous appelle mon père alors très bien
moi je vous êtes catholique je crois oui
je suis catholique oui mon père bien
alors il est né en 1935 au croisic
éducation traditionnelle voire
traditionalistes alors vous avez été
élevé dans la mythologie de la anti
révolutionnaires contre révolution des
révolutionnaires qu'à l'époque on vous
expliquer la terreur vous avez été élevé
dans le culte des chouans dans loin de
là la résolution i les charrettes sont
des cousins voyez c'est ça oui c'est
vraiment voilà alors c'est vrai il faut
dire quand même que bon tout ça n'est
pas non plus innocent c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque sur la loire on mettait des
gens dans des bateaux et on perd c'est
le fond ces fameux carrier qui devrait
ça donc il ya quand même des raisons
wyatt de la loi voilà la terreur en eaux
froides voilà il est aussi le génocide
vendéen qui qui est reconnu comme un
génocide
alors quand vous avez 24 ans vous donnez
séminaristes à rome par vaux j'ai appris
l'italien voilà retombées négatives ngp
manuel
honnêtement quand vous devenez
séminaristes et l'âge de 24 ans as rome
est ce que c'est par vocation parce que
le milieu dans lequel vous aviez été
élevé vous y poussent c'est une bonne
question ô mon seigneur les deux mois il
ya une vraie vocation qui vient de la
lecture d'un auteur à thé dieu sociale
de tous y compris les athées parfois des
princes pour appeler à lui je n'avais
pas envie d'être curé ça c'est certain
mais dans le contexte de l'époque aller
jusqu'au bout de l'absolu de dieu
c'était ce faire prêtre
vous aviez vraiment la foi quoi ao
complètement sa pas varié d'un pouce
sens contraire elle augmente chaque jour
et même en vous voyant
x
et comme chante si bien ophélie winter
dieu lui a donné la foi alors fait des
études de philo de théologie à l'époque
alors on faisait trois ans de philo
ensuite on faisait de service militaire
en faisait quatre ans de théologie dans
ça fait sept ans 28 mois d'algérie vingt
films en algérie alors à l'époque la
rumeur courait déjà qu'on pratiqué la
torture en algérie
voyez à cause de votre éducation vous ne
pouviez pas y croire parce que pour vous
les officiers c'était le symbole de
l'honneur de la civilisation et vous
trouviez scandaleux même qu'on puisse
les soupçonner de torture et les
officiers français tout à fait j'étais
dans la mythologie de lyautey de
larigaudie enfin des grands noms que les
jeunes ne connaissent pas ton chez ricoh
gr et donc imaginé un officier français
en train de torturer
c'est à dire d'attenté à la dignité de
la personne humaine me paraissait
absolument impossible ouais ouais
et en fait quand vous arrivez en algérie
vous découvrez effectivement que l'armée
française pratiquer la torture s'est
tenue à 35 terrible pour nous c'est un
choc
c'est pas le seul choc ya aussi la
misère il ya des amendes oui et puis à
l'idhec à 18 ans un jeune algérien
devant les carences de la colonisation
française ne pouvait prendre que son
fugier aller dans le djebel donc je
découvre ce qu'est la révolution oui
effectivement 28 mois en algérie comme
officier vous luttez contre la torture
vous luttez ensuite contre l'abandon des
harkis parce que ça aussi il faut le
dire c'est comme une noyade dans la
loire il faut tout dire que l'histoire
faut dire quand même que la france a
abandonné 150000 harkis en algérie qui
ont été égorgés dès que les français
sont partis en 62 voilà alors on vous
menace
à l'époque on vous dit oui mais vous
vous révolter contre la torture
c'est pas bon pour votre dossier à rome
ce serait mauvais pour ma carrière j'ai
pas changé depuis
ouais non il avait la panoplie des mecs
a réussi à rome il est pas déguiser en
waterman en tous les cas ça vous a pas
empêché effectivement je dis oh pas de
réussir enfin quand même de faire une
carrière au sein de l'église est une
réussite et vous chevauchez au jugement
dernier jeu passera ses matricule ray
c'est pour ça qu'il ya la pression ces
derniers tirent la gueule de l'audimat
c'est gentil mais ça ne fait que a lâché
en mai par rapport au jugement dernier
ne fait rien ça c'est clair
alors en 63 vous est ordonné prêtre
ensuite vous cofondé radio notre dame
vous écrivez un livre sur la torture en
algérie en 90 mais personne n'a parlé
c'était à l'entrée par l'âme dans la
pègre en 92 vous devenez l'aumônier du
monde politique à l'initiative du
cardinal lustiger
est ce que vous étiez un peu on pourrait
dire le représentant du lobby catho tout
à fait je revendique le maul au but j'ai
écrit un article dans le figaro
latchoumanin de monsieur d'ormesson a
prononcé ce mot et que certains autres
lobbies sont scandalisés chantal par
exemple eh eh bien j'ai dit oui et
pourquoi mais pourquoi il irait pas un
lobby catho ouais vous étiez les
formations voilà oui vous représentez or
qu'est ce que vous faisiez vous
organisez des des petites fleurs et
grande soirée vraie amitié des hommes
politiques annoncées pas à côté petit
four et moulin non c'était du vrai
boulot hein on était consultant
théologique way premier horizons
politiques
oui tout à fait donc chaque groupe
parlementaire en général un référent il
ya le dr un tel que spécialiste de tels
partis etc
mais d'autres ont envie de se faire une
idée il s'appelle le consultant est
d'accord et ils disent vont expliquer
nous un petit peu à la limite y en a qui
nous dise comment il faut voter
ouais je dis non mais j'ai pas là pour
vous dire comment il faut voter
j'éclaire votre lanterne
et vous êtes tout seul pour voter il
alors dit moi mon père vous avez les
confessions des hommes politiques est né
ce qu'on fait c'est chez vous à 7 ils
tranchaient de votre porte sur une
question plus originales et alors que si
vous racontez là comme la confession sa
200 salles chance purement sacramentelle
on va voir le prête on dit j'ai péché on
demande le pardon de dieu et c'est le
secret professionnel absolu ça c'est le
rite sacramentelle et il ya les
confessions dans le sens large du terme
ou un homme politique vient me dire j'ai
un problème parce que ma femme c'est que
je la trompe
mais j'en fais une quitter l'islam a dit
qu'il échappe énormément non achetés
chez plutôt un mec moralement pas mal
bien alors je vais pas faire campagne
chercher un autre sérieusement quand il
veut et ce qu'on fait c'est en dehors de
leur affaire de sexe
est-ce qui vous disaient des fois j'ai
détourné de l'argent mon père je suis
désolé mais il ya eu des problèmes de
corruption mais j'ai été le confident
ouais alors on vous a accusé à l'époque
vous étiez donc l'aumônier du monde
politique d'être intrigant beaucoup et
on vous a pour vous à taxer de
balladurisme à attention attention je
suis en train de porter plainte contre
un une journaliste qui ressort ce propos
diffamatoires dont j'entends depuis cinq
ans oui je sais c'est que je vais à la
répondait là vous êtes vous êtes à la
télé et bien justement toi mon fils je
dis non avant non déontologique mans
pendant les présidentielles je n'ai
parlé ni de jacques delors avec qui
j'avais d'excellents rapports mieux
qu'avec balladur je n'ai parlé ni jack
double- edouard balladur ni de jacques
chirac
les chiraquiens vous êtes d'accord vous
ont reproché d'être balladuriens mais ça
les arrangeait way puis qu'il avait peur
de balladur ouais enfin bon dieu vous a
quand même fait chevalier de la légion
d'honneur
oui et j'ai même demandé au cardinal si
je vais accepter me répondu oui parce
que l'on honore la fonction que moi j'ai
créé un bon d'accord donc le cardinal
était d'accord bien rage elle avait
refusé au départ
voilà
[Applaudissements]
vous daignez tout à fait 7 a
complètement cessé
je porte plainte en diffamation contre
une journaliste puis cinq adhérents si
quelqu'un si quelqu'un traite alain de
la morandais de balladur ici vous portez
ballade you lie pas un peuple en
bataille tension laurent la vengeance
vengeance divine alors recompter vous
leur vend très bien on va les laisser
reposer à thouarcé l'on sait combien tu
regardes soir pour une connerie
hanaoka change puisque dans l'éternité
le temps ne compte pas voilà c'est quoi
la fin de l'été un été chaud comprend il
ya enfin d'être si peu angoissant alors
vous méprenez pas alors et justement ce
week-end à un meilleure chose dont
jamais de fin sauf les émission
d'ardisson alors vous êtes débarquer
les jours de séminaire pour gaza c'est
un bosseur philosophie théologie sept
ans à rome mon père vous êtes débarqué
par lustiger quand même à un moment
parce que pourquoi parce qu'ils
n'arrivent plus à vous défendre auprès
de chirac
je n'ai pas de comptes à régler avec mon
patron pourquoi parce que les ennemis de
l'église serait trop content de
récupérer la chose au match donc je ne
dis rien on voit qu'il a été levée à
rome quand même récupérer les choses à
ma bouche je dis quand même
alors on peut dire est ce qu'on peut
dire que vous êtes en pénitence depuis
cinq ans ah oui rapport au franc que tu
veux dire non et en pénitence non mais
sérieux depuis cinq ans vous avez plus
de fonctions vous vous occupez d'une
chapelle qui s'appelle la chapelle
l'agneau de dieu qui a été construite
sur l'îlot de chalon ouais à l'endroit
où on a cherché un endroit autrefois
mais oui c'est vrai comment vous savez
fort exactement à lille où j'ai acheté
de la poudre à l'époque c'est vrai que
l'arrêt des colonies et maintenant il ya
une église
voilà et voilà l'orbit bien aussi
beaucoup de hdf ouais vous venez en aide
aux sans abri aussi il faut le brûler je
travaille beaucoup là dessus et vous
publiez un avis vous savez comment on
fait mon père non je vous dire un truc
di falco l'a fait ben il est prêt à tout
mais pas facile mais moi non
le baby l'a fait mais pas exprès au
pardon oui là là là je prends trois ans
de purgatoire est pas là je suis content
élever le débat
moi j'ai peur des jumeaux vernis en plus
bien alors voulait pas faire des câlins
d'oise bon bah emmanuel fait ses petits
gimat le coince le fait à la place du
reggae mon père délégué
bien on a gagné notre place voilà le
livre s'appelle la communion des [ __ ]
sécher la thèse c'est votre premier
roman c'est toujours votre obsession de
la torture en algérie n'y a pas que ya
pas que ça moi je sens que c'est ça
l'art alcan bien mechmache en thuya mai
68 alors je fais le pitch ouais laurent
16 en algérie en 61 qui assiste à une
scène de torture qui s'achève en abus
sexuels et deux mois plus tard il est
violet sur la route de saint jacques de
compostelle laura adapté voilà il se
demande si c'est pas une punition de la
justice immanente
et ensuite il l'air à travers le monde
en se réfugiant auprès du père grégoire
il cherche la réponse à cette question
là c'est une façon un peu sommaire de
résumer votre bouquin mais enfin alors
la première question que vous me posez
c'est est-ce que le fait d'aller faire
ce pèlerinage à saint jacques de
compostelle
est-ce que c'est pas déjà une preuve de
sa culpabilité qu'il admet sa
culpabilité qu'il y va pour se grimer
vous car il a assisté sans rien dire à
cette scène de théâtre j'avais presque
tout compris il fait sa propre en
repentance en faisant ce pèlerinage
alors qu'il est apte et parce qu'il a
conscience qu'il aurait dû ouvrir sa
gueule
ouais bien sûr donc est la communion des
saints et la communion des [ __ ] basse
et l'autre c'est ce qui donne le titre
de votre de votre roman est ce que est
ce que cette autobiographie xvi est
arrivé comme j'ai tjrs en algérie les 28
mois vous avez passé là bas
est-ce que vous avez assisté agca j'ai
revu ressens rien dit j'ai été témoin
non non j'ai été témoin de chêne qui
fort des preuves dans ce genre
d'affaires c'est sérieux oui donc il
faut avoir des preuves j'ai été appelé
par un jeune lieutenant comme moi qui
était appelé pour dire viens voir vite à
la ferme il se passe des choses donc je
suis arrivé avec la jeep et mon officier
mon ordonnance est très rapidement j'ai
vu le début j'ai fait sécher évidemment
avancé et après j'ai pu protester parce
que j'avais des preuves
d'accord vous avez jamais assisté à une
scène de torture sans rien dire c'est
pas un énorme raz sensible le père de
laurent
est un action française dix ans un
enfant sage ils savent pas ce que c'est
le respect justement on sait des
royalistes d'extrême droite de l'avant
guerre
est-ce que vous votre famille et tes
actions françaises oui mon grand-père de
l'action française mon père était est
mort en camp de concentration à doha
parce qu'il sauvait les juifs
ah bon il y avait une partie de la
famille dans la résistance et une partie
un peu contre révolutionnaire
ouais le père était un injuste donc
comme on dit alors le père grégoire que
va voir le héros de votre livre laurent
il s'appelle grégoire de bois saint lys
il a un peu le même cursus que vous ils
étaient à bord
là c'est presque autobiographique à
d'accord c'est à dire en fait c'est le
personnage que j'aurais pu être si
j'avais pas changé d'accord bah oui
c'est ça c'est plus l'algérie que
j'aurais pu devenir
voici une astuce pour les futurs
romancier tu te projettes en le disant
voilà ce que je suis mais il faudrait
peut-être pas trop de choses pour que je
sois ça use ça use ça encore alors le
coeur de votre livre se passant en
ardèche donc lorsque laurent va
rencontrer le père grégoire est aumônier
militaire alors une grande conversation
il dit l'église a fait repentance sur
l'inquisition sur le locaux sur l'
esclavage mais pas sur les crimes
colonialiste ce qui s'est passé à
madagascar est ce qui s'est passé en
algérie l'abandon des harkis
est-ce que vous pensez que l'église
aujourd'hui devrait faire repentance et
oui d'ailleurs
un peu avant les présidentielles nous
allons organiser quelques colloque avec
des politiques et faire à l'appel public
à l'état et à l'église de france pour
qu'ils repentance pour la torture et
surtout pour les harkis massue a reconnu
dans le monde le 23 juin 2000 il a
reconnu qu'il y avait eu de la torture
affirme inquiet par l'armée française en
algérie
il a même dit que c'était inutile et et
le général bigeard a dit que c'était un
tissu de mensonges mais bigeard il est
vieux puis l'a toujours est un peu
mégalo il est déconnecté quoi ah je vais
quand même plaidé pour lui il n'a pas eu
de formation morale c'est vrai ça cause
beaucoup
non mais on n'a pas le droit d'envoyer
des officiers dans des situations
difficiles
lorsqu'ils n'ont pas eu la bonne
formation pour résister à des tentations
évidente
donc faut pas transformer les militaires
en boucs émissaires les vraies
responsabilités sur ce problème
elles sont du côté politique droite et
gauche confondues
oui et le président françois mitterrand
à quelques responsabilités sur laquelle
l'ex ministre de l'intérieur n'est ce
pas n'est ce pas et il fermait et je
dois dire qu'en ce que les gaullistes ne
connaissent pas leur histoire que le
général de gaulle a envoyé une
circulaire dès son arrivée au pouvoir en
58 à son ministre de la défense de
l'époque guillaume a pour interdire les
méthodes 1 alors monseigneur bérenger
qui est évêque de saint-denis
oui car elles ont condisciples à rome
voilà a été mandatée par le cardinal
j'imagine pour gérer je dirais la
repentance par rapport à ce qui s'est
passé pendant pendant la guerre donc le
low cost
et quand on lui a dit qu'il fallait
faire la même chose pour la guerre
d'algérie pour la torture etc
les harkis il a dit il n'ya pas de lobby
en ce sens en france rim l'indien mois
un jus répondu mais t'en fais pas en
vain créé un ouais vous pensez que
bientôt tout ça va être souhaite comme
vichy servi chine depuis dix ans bon là
on a tout mis sur la table
vous pensez que ça va être pareil pour
l'algérie ça va se faire peu à peu ce
qu'il faut c'est que ça se fasse
calmement sans règlement de comptes sans
violence et dans la sérénité parce que
le denim le déni de mémoire n'est jamais
bon pour aucune génération
il faut savoir ce qu'on fait les grands
pères les pertes de façon à ce que les
jeunes générations soient de plus en
plus franche et nette par rapport à
leurs enfants
et ça on y arrivera et là il ya un
progrès est ce que vous pensez que les
fans aiment le faire la même chose ça
mais ils ont tellement de problèmes plus
graves à régler la bac
par là il fonce dans 50 ans ouais alors
ce qui vous gêne un peu c'est que cette
initiative de repentance sur la torture
en algérie viennent les communistes dont
vous dites oui avec un set à londres
banalisant la chaîne wii sont mal placés
pour nous faire la leçon
oui non surtout pas écouter ya le goulag
il ya le fait que le parti communiste a
été à fermer sa gueule pendant longtemps
pendant la guerre d'algérie sous le
gouvernement de guy mollet et ensuite à
une attitude qui était pas clair du tout
ils ont vraiment mis le temps alors bon
il faut repenser maintenant moi je veux
bien mais c'est pas à eux de nous donner
des leçons alors au delà de ce problème
est ce que ça ne pose pas tout
simplement le problème de l'obéissance
c'est à dire c'est finalement papon tous
ces gens là il était quand même au
service d'un pouvoir politique à un
moment il ya un donné il ya un devoir de
désobéissance à d'accord voilà c'est ce
que je veux les entendre dire bien sûr
et donc un devoir d élection survient
cinq ans quand vous disiez tout à
l'heure que s'il fallait pas incriminer
l'armée mais le pouvoir politique est
bien l'armé n'a pas usé de ses pouvoirs
désobéit général de bollardière m
l'obscur l'ont fait oui c'est à dire
sans grades
il y en a pas tous une minorité comme
d'habitude comme d'habitude mais enfin
comme de gaulle en 40
oui des homélies et que ça à l'armée qui
est parti à londres d'accord alors
passer maintenant à au catholicisme en
france aujourd'hui il n'est pas très
bien traité
on en parle souvent ici on voit le pape
aux guignols qui prend de la coke on n'a
jamais vu de rabbins prendre de la coke
aux guignols sur canal on n'a jamais vu
dit mam prendre de la coke aux guignols
sur canal vous avez sans doute lu le
livre de rené rémy 1
est ce que vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui
donc comme rené rémond le catholicisme
en france finalement été maltraités et
traitée comme une autre et les
maltraités mais le pire serait qu'ils
deviennent indifférent ouais donc moi je
trouve que badiou qu'on en parle c'est
bien parce qu'au moins on peut répondre
ça doit être dur quand même aujourd'hui
d'être disons prêtre médiatique quand on
vous parle de la capote pendant lequel
vous pouvez répondre ben je me dis que
ils en sont encore là ils n'ont pas
compris quoi est ce week-end ou alors le
pape est chargé de donner le top le plus
haut ouais qui après nous on gère on
gère on est à la base on dit bah écoute
tu fais ce que tu peux si tu veux on ne
peut pas vraiment faire autre chose que
de besoin mais en moi ne prend pas de
risques d'akena maire de pas l'autre
gala mais tu sais ce serait mieux deux
d'accord non ces jeux élever le débat
c'est mieux de pas trompé sa femme et
sur la trompe mettant une capote
c'est comme la question que j'ai entendu
thaler sur les maisons closes sur les
rebelles l'idéal c'est si tous les
couples étaient heureux ils répondent
bordel un pot avec des maîtres comme
l'est le mariage des plaques ans tous
les deux jours dont à la télé on nous
explique qu'il ya un curé pédophile qui
se tape un gamin de 8 ans est ce que si
les prêts de se marier ce serait quand
même pas plus sain carrière du chanteur
ne change rien du tout parce qu'il ya le
même cachet des instituteurs marié ouais
donc il ya un vrai problème le problème
à la fois dans l'éducation nationale
comme dans l'église c'est d'arriver à
discerner au départ et c'est très
difficile
quelles sont les tendances de quelqu'un
qui va s'occuper des plus jeunes car
souvent eux mêmes ne le savent pas 1 à
20 ans ou à 25 ans alors c'est là où il
ya un devoir de vigilance de la part de
l'éducation nationale et de l'église
vous pensé mon premier chef évidemment
pensez pas que le mariage des prêtres
non pas entre eux mais avec des femmes
résoudre l résoudrait le problème mais
j'ai trop de respect pour le mariage
pour penser que ce soit un remède comme
solution ça ferait du bien comme on n'en
est pas là c'est ici un peu comme un
bien est ce que vous pensez
je n'ai rien contre le fait que plus
tard après jean paul ii y est voilà des
prêtres mariés au contraire ce que
j'allais vous dire est ce que vous
pensez pas que bon jean paul ii il a
fait beaucoup il a déjà détruit il a
détruit le communiste puis ce qui est
déjà beaucoup alors est ce que vous
pensez pas que le jour il sera plus là
un pape un peu plus moderne pourra être
plus coulants disons surtout s'agit pas
d'être cool hein il s'agit de changer
les paramètres les exigences pour les
rendre possible et humain vous pensez
que jean paul ii risque de démissionner
là non parce qu'il ya quand même 183
cardinaux qui sont les deux raisons pour
lesquelles il ne démissionnera pas pas
plus que françois mitterrand quand on
est au pouvoir on est un peu prisonnier
d'un entourage dans toujours âge a
toujours intérêt à ce que le pouvoir
reste et d'en profiter dans les
meilleures chances du terme et
deuxièmement c'est un homme d'un
volontarisme et dans l'héroïsme
extraordinaire donc il n'est pas
psychologiquement vraisemblable que
quelqu'un qui est volontariste héroïque
dis-je
je me retire il avait l'impression
justement de faillir voir son héroïsme
vous pas pensé qu'il mourra sur place
tout à fait comme molière
al amam au rendez vous êtes prêtre vous
avez croyant donc je vais vous faire une
interview croyances
[Musique]
ma
[Applaudissements]
j'ai péché mon père j'ai bougé pour
l'attribution de pélicans je crois que
ma fille offrira une coupe de champagne
en sortant est ce que vous croyez au
diable oui bien sûr quand je vous vois
[Applaudissements]
rak thai un rire sardonique rire
diabolique ya verges h c'est pire oui
aux besoins du vergès oui c'est vrai est
ce que vous croyez que la france va
gagner l'eurovision cette année
oui évidemment parlé tout à l'heure avec
natasha st pier et au ces pour la fois
si vous croyez aux extraterrestres non
aux anges
oui ça existe les hanches wii auront
moins esthétiquement et poétiquement et
artistiquement et pourquoi pas sûr
naturellement vrai les anges gardiens
moyen âge que je prie toujours avant de
venir à l'émission de télévision vrai
c'est l'ange des vanités oui disent ouf
le mois sur la gueule pour que je me
prenne pas trop syrien sait bien que je
ne me gonfle pas de panique le sait bien
c'est raté et l'ange-gardien s'aggrave
il y en a déjà mais oui il faudrait que
les agents de sexe bien sûr des anges
gardiens même au ps je viens de plus
grand bien vu
il faut que j'explique au prince qui a
des plaisirs plus grands que ceux du
shaq away ah ouais bah c'est un gros que
tard et 3
quand il sera roi il aura besoin vous
aurez besoin d'avoir quelqu'un comme
situation rend très cher bien entendu je
vous dit rien on voit très bien tu me
vois très bien confesseur auprès d'un
pouce il a rien dit sur tous les hommes
politiques mais elle a dit qu'il y avait
des bons tuyaux invitera après il n'y a
rien non c'est clair mais y'a carlos de
bourbon a qui me demandent aussi des
bonbons - 6/10 fait 700 personnes tous
les soirs philippe tesson dit que c'est
un génie qu'est ce que je vous dise oui
il continue est ce que vous croyez à
l'efficacité des crèmes antirides hansen
m'intéresse pas du tout s'il a laissé
l'occasion géré par aju
ces questionnaires la saison placebo
vous croyez à la réincarnation à la
réincarnation non je crois la
résurrection ce qui est très différent
expliquez-nous mais la réincarnation
c'est s'imaginer que lorsqu'on a été
lent gushue a marre oui et qu'on a pêché
on va devenir les mains peau dégradation
de plus en plus bas et qu'au contraire
quand on était bien on va devenir
baleines et ensuite colibri couet alors
que la résurrection c'est lorsque vous
croyez il ya un raciste animalier
terrible pourquoi pourquoi colibri cmuc
baleine j'ai pas dit que dieu sait si
bien joué
alors là les chais et la résurrection
c'est très différent c'est de croire
qu'après la mort l'amour est plus fort
que la vie et que la création est
tellement belle qu'elle remettra avec
nous avec des corps mais avec déplaisir
infiniment supérieurs à ceux des cinq
directions des corps
bien je ne méprise pas de sexe ah non
mais j'espère bien ni dedans
est ce que vous croyez que chirac sera
réélu en 2002 aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
j'espère car à un groupe qui se formera
qui s'appellera tout sauf chirac
un groupe de rock à la mort l'arrêt mais
y'a bayrou qui va se présenter a mis
d'accord c'est vrai à aa
c'est pas un technocrate c'est un vrais
paysans il a fait une très belle
biographie du roi henri iv
bien entendu nous bien il a des racines
et le charisme en plus moi et je n'en
avais pas faut dire que bayrou chez les
démocrates chrétiens quand même c'est
plus votre truc quoi mais chirac c'est à
ce point là quand même
mais qu'est ce qui t'a fait jure bien
est ce que vous croyez à la mort d'elvis
non vie ce n'est pas mort il ya 20 % des
américains qui pensent comme vous mon
père est ce que vous croyez au sexe sans
amour annoncé le pire qui puisse arriver
à et est ce que vous croyez à l'amour
son sexe oui je suis un objet la
communion
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'ina l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
peu de bleu